a Texas sheriff says officers who
responded to the Santa Fe High School
shooting prevented an even bigger
tragedy eight students and two
substitute teachers were killed at Santa
Fe High on Friday the 17 year old
suspect is now being held under suicide
watch at the county jail
Omar Villafranca spoke with the
Galveston County Sheriff he's outside
the high school with more on this story
Omar good morning good morning the
memorial here at the high school
continues to grow you can see these ten
white crosses behind me one for each
victim
we're also learning more about the case
including a possible motive four minutes
after the first calls came in to
dispatch to school police officers
confronted the alleged gunman
Demetrius pig or cheese in a classroom
they traded gunshots with him from the
hallway according to the Galveston
County Sheriff Henry Trotter said
anytime children are shot teachers are
shot in and that number is horrific is
it possible that these students and
teachers and other victims could have
been hit by friendly fire I won't firmly
know that answer until after the
autopsies
officer John Barnes was shot during the
confrontation and is recovering in the
intensive care unit he's had ups and
downs today is a down day teachers
Cynthia Tisdale was among those killed
her son Reece a detective responded to
the shooting he issued a statement
through a spokeswoman it was very hard
to go from assisting others to being
horribly affected by this tragic event
there are no words to explain how
saddened my entire family is for
everyone involved
attorneys for pig or cheese say they're
looking into allegations the teenager
was bullied at school the suspects
father told a Greek television station
he owned a shotgun and pistol used
during the massacre he described his son
as quote a good boy I'm having a funeral
he said I have the same exact pain I'm
sorry the school will reopen May 29 but
some parents worried their children are
T traumatized to go back
my granddaughter goes to school
what do you tell them you get some
counseling for them they're going to get
through this her best friend is murdered
they are going to get through this but
it's tough on them
today Texas governor Greg Abbott will
host a series of roundtable meetings
with students teachers lawmakers and
advocates on both sides of the gun issue
the topic school safety all right
Omar thank you you think about that
students having to go back to school
it's really hard they're scared and how
do they do that and carry on as if
nothing has happened there you their
lives will never ever be the same I
wonder about that too that's right and
any student going to any other school I
mean when you see so many pictures of
this and you think of students you know
who might be a little upset you know
that's up in their place yes everyone's
scared